welcome back to CBS mornings now we've
got a lot more on the threat of a
worsening triple endemic this winter the
CDC says hospitalizations for RSV and
the flu are starting to decline but
Health experts predict infections for
covid and these other viruses will jump
as a result of holiday celebrations and
travel Dr William Schaffner is an
infectious disease specialist at
Vanderbilt University Medical Center in
nationally joins us now good morning
doctor
good morning good to be with you good to
be with you uh so of the three viruses
covid RSV and the flu which has you most
concerned and more importantly what can
people do to protect themselves
well at the moment I'm most concerned
about flu because although the CDC says
that cases have diminished in many parts
of the country you know that was before
the holidays and we have New Year's
coming up so I anticipate that with all
of the travel all of the confusion all
the joyous reunions over the holidays
there will be many opportunities for
these for this virus this influenza
virus to be transmitted and spread even
further so I anticipate that we are
going to have a post-holiday surge for
sure
Dr Schaffner we've been talking a lot
about the shortage in children's
medicine I have friends of mine who are
calling each other saying I found some
Tylenol here do you need some what
should parents do right now
I think talk to their pediatricians
these medications are for symptomatic
relief so it's not as though their
children are going to get worse in any
way but the pediatricians can sometimes
help them adapt adult medication for
Pediatric use but you want to talk to
your doctor because you want the dose to
be right depending upon the size of your
child
Dr Schaffner there's also been strep a
infections that have killed at least two
children in the U.S and even more in
Europe what else do we know about this
so rupe strep is that bug that of course
causes sore throat but occasionally when
a virus has inflamed the back of the
throat the nose and the bronchial tubes
these throat bacteria can get through
the protection of the mucous membranes
and get into the bloodstream causing
more serious infections you know parents
if your children look in any way ill
they're having any difficulty please
contact your health care provider we can
treat these infections very successfully
so doctor let me ask you to speculate a
bit here uh when might we see this
ripple effect from all these infections
in other words when we look to the new
year at about what time will we see a
lot of Americans that are sick from
these infections that are happening
because of travel and celebrations
well sometime already this week because
of all the Christmas and other travel
and then of course after the New Year's
because of all of those New Year parties
getting together so the week after and
two weeks after New Year's we anticipate
that we'll see an increase again in many
of these respiratory infections
including the common cold covid perhaps
RSV kicking back up again and for sure
influenza so particularly people who are
older who are frail have underlying
illnesses or immune compromised and if
you're pregnant if you're going out in
crowds still wear that mask and remember
it's not too late to get vaccinated
I love that PSA Dr Shafter speaking of
vaccinations in covid it's estimated
that 95 of Americans have coveted
antibodies does that mean that this
winter season is going to be a little
bit less severe in terms of covid
hopefully
oh yes I think that that's the case
we're not going to have a surge the way
we did last year and the year before but
remember covet is still out there
causing the death of somewhere around
300 Americans every single day if we
hadn't had the surge before we would all
be very excited about that so it's still
a nasty virus out there if you haven't
received the updated covet booster
please don't linger get it as soon as
possible
300 American deaths a day Dr William
Schaffner thank you so much